this is from the daily wire says uh
representative rashida talib rejected
calls from within her party to curb
progressive sloganeering such as defund
the police asserting that such calls
amounted to silencing her and her voters
um talib pushed back against the calls
to moderate in an interview with
politico on tuesday
moderates in the party have blamed poor
results in a number of close races
on extreme stances of many prominent
democrats like talib and alexandra casa
cortez
um and she says this is this is the
quote i wanted to get to she says we are
not interested this is to leap
we're not interested in unity that asks
people to sacrifice their freedom and
their rights any longer
and if we truly want to unify our
country we have to really respect every
single voice we say that
we say that uh so willingly when we talk
about trump supporters but we don't say
that willingly for my black and brown
neighbors and from
lgbtq neighbors or marginalized people
okay she she towards the end there of
course she's getting into
nonsense but um i agree
actually with the first part of what you
said
we're not interested in unity that asks
people to sacrifice their freedom and
their rights
um i would also add to that
i'm speaking for myself i'm not
interested in that kind of unity either
i'm also not interested in unity that
requires people to sacrifice their
convictions
and their beliefs and their principles
and values
uh to include you know their religious
convictions because that's
that's the kind of unity that democrats
want that's the kind of unity that
rasheed talib wants
so yeah a unity
that requires people to give up these
essential aspects of themselves and of
being an american
that is not a unity that i want it's not
unity that she wants
it's just that the problem is you know
she considers
it it's we have a we also have a very
fundamental difference
an opinion on what a right and a freedom
actually is
so she believes for example that of
course parents have the
god-given we're not parents sorry
mothers specifically
have the god-given right to murder their
offspring
that's what she believes um
and that's another reason why there
can't be unity
because we we can't even agree on what a
right is
or what a freedom is you put
i say this all the time you put 100
americans into a room and you do a poll
and you ask them you know what what are
our most basic and fundamental rights
you're not even going to get like a you
certainly will not get above a 50
agreement on that and that's why there
can't be unity
i mean we're not even i i don't feel
like i'm living in the same universe
as a person who thinks that a mother has
a god-given right to murder her
offspring
as opposed to a god-given mandate to
care for her offspring
i also don't feel like i'm in a universe
with the same universe with someone who
thinks that
you know a mother can also be a
biological male by the way
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated